the lost world Jurassic Park is directed
by Steven Spielberg and stars Jeff
Goldblum Julianne Moore and Vince Vaughn
and is the sequel to the incredibly
successful Jurassic Park now if you're
not following me on Facebook and Twitter
you would not have seen that I said I
wanted to cover the remaining Jurassic
Park films before Jurassic world comes
out next month I already reviewed
Jurassic Park when the 3d re-release
happened you can watch that review it's
been on my channel for a couple years
now so I'd like to cover the last two
that I've never talked about the lost
world Jurassic Park and Jurassic Park 3
which is coming up very soon and just as
a warning if you've never seen lost
world there's going to be some spoilers
throughout this review I would suggest
checking out the movie and then coming
back and watching my review then so the
filmmakers had a bit of a challenge with
this movie how do you get these
characters back to a place that's so
horrible once they leave they're not
going to go back for any specific reason
just to hang out with some dinosaurs
that almost killed them last time but I
think they devised the best possible way
see Hammond wants people to go in there
and do some research about these
dinosaurs because engine is trying to
take control of that company away from
Hammond one of the people sent just so
happens to be Jeff Goldblum's girlfriend
played by Julianne Moore so himself to
others and his stowaway daughter end up
on this island in search for Sarah and
once they eventually find her of course
dinosaurs start eating people now when I
grew up I love this movie I thought it
was so great I never understood why
people never really liked this one I
never understood the hate that it got I
rewatched the movie today and I still
don't understand what people don't like
it and I still don't understand why it
gets hate because I actually think this
is a great movie let me explain before
you might get upset because a lot of
people don't enjoy the lost world it's a
bit of an unpopular opinion on my part
and have a lot of defenses for why I
feel this way for one I think it's
unfairly compared to Jurassic Park a lot
I think people went into this movie
expecting the exact same type of movie
again but Spielberg actually made a huge
effort to make a very different movie a
completely different movie he did the
very same thing with Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom a lot of people did
not like that movie at first for quite
some time it got a lot of hate because
it was too dark it was too different
from Raiders Oh Lost Ark I actually
loved
of doom I love how it's different I love
how he actually made a unique movie that
wasn't just another Raiders Oh Lost Ark
and he did it again with the lost world
and it's one of my favorite parts about
this film it's actually a very different
movie from its first movie and not for
any particular reason that you can
easily identify it still carries the
same themes as the first film man
interfering with nature not good just
leave it alone if we leave nature alone
allow nature to take its course
nature then can survive and flourish and
things won't all go to hell as long as
men isn't interfering those are the
themes of Jurassic Park and they're all
prevalent throughout the lost world you
have the Injun Army on the island trying
to take some of these dinosaurs back to
San Diego to create a zoo you see all
the trouble that that causes and then
you have our main group of heroes who
are just trying to survive the themes of
the film are very similar to the first
one but the difference here is is the
entire structure of the movie the first
film was about this incredible
uninspiring idea of people discovering
this area in which you could view
dinosaurs almost every scene had a mouth
dropping just wonder inducing moment
this movie was more about exploring Ian
Malcolm's character his relationship
with Sarah Harding played by Julianne
Moore who's excellent in this movie and
the fact that he's seen all of this
before it was one of my favorite things
about this movie as I rewatched it Ian
Malcolm is constantly interacting with
people going oh ah yes so yes that's how
it starts and then later there's running
and screaming and hmm is it as good as
the first Jurassic Park no it's not but
it's a very different movie and I
respect it for that it does have its
problems and I'll get into that soon but
the things I love about this movie are
that it maintains such a great feeling
of adventure and suspense throughout
almost its entire runtime Spielberg as
always proves himself a master crafter
behind the camera in almost every scene
he gets these incredible long takes like
for instance a scene in which Eddie is
trying to tie the trailer to this tree
stump we go in a tracking shot from the
tree stump following Eddie into the
trailer and then over the cliff into the
other trailer and you see our characters
below all in one shot and the idea of
setting all this up is just
mind-boggling
and he continues to have shots like that
throughout the
movie which also support that reputation
that Spielberg has developed for himself
for finishing ahead of schedule because
he gets so much in one shot he creates
these incredible scenes and does things
that a lot of filmmakers might do 7 or 8
setups in one take and it's fantastic
it's great to watch just one of the
opening shots alone you see a guy
walking on a beach you think you're
following this person then we rack focus
to a bottle of wine no that's not we're
following we're actually following this
family we're seeing this family lounging
on a beach no we're actually following
the little girl who has a sandwich
Spielberg does these amazing things with
the camera throughout the whole movie
and it always keeps you second-guessing
in a movie about dinosaurs on an island
something that used to be a b-movie
claymation in the 1930s and 40s also
this movie has one of my favorite cuts
in cinema of all time it's near the very
beginning you see the mother reacting to
her daughter being eaten alive by these
copies she screams and we cut directly
to a sound of a subway screeching to a
halt and Jeff Goldblum yawning behind
him is this thing that looks like he's
on some island somewhere but no actually
we pan with him and we're in a subway
station it's one of my favorite cuts in
cinema scream - yawn you think you're on
a beach nope you're in a subway it's
just this type of filmmaking that no
other director out there puts that much
thought into and of course you never
feel like you're on a set you constantly
feel like you're in a real environment
on a real island with real gigantic
crowds of people moving along this
forest with the ocean in the background
the waves breaking up on the rocks all
of these things that really lend to the
idea of realism in this movie and of
course just like in the first film the
animatronics and the creatures are
mind-blowing and by far the best one in
this movie is the baby t-rex because
it's held by Vince Vaughn it's carried
around is carried through a trailer it
looks like it's suffering when I watched
it with my wife she was like oh the baby
t-rex said it's legs and it's like she
was like worried about it because this
robot was so convincing and speaking of
that trailer scene for me it might rival
the scene in which the t-rex is
introduced in Jurassic Park where the
parent t-rex is knocked the trailer
halfway over the cliff we get that
amazing suspense scene with Julianne
Moore
like on the glass like holy don't
move it is fantastic suspense filmmaking
and I do not think this movie gets
enough credit now let's talk about some
of my issues with this movie because
yeah there are some the scene with the
gymnastics it's dumb it's stupid or Jeff
Goldblum's daughter swings on the two
bars and knocks the Raptor out of the
window his joke at the end almost makes
it work when he's like a school cut you
from the team like it's funny but the
entire sequence it's it's only about 15
seconds of movie okay it's not like Shia
LaBeouf swinging from vines for like
three minutes it's about 15 seconds of a
stupid part in a cool scene the rest of
the scene is awesome it's totally badass
with these Raptors jumping everywhere
it's great stuff that stupid moment is
dumb and I don't like it but it's very
brief my other issue is the San Diego
sequence but not the sequence itself the
getting to said sequence it's so abrupt
it honestly feels like 20 minutes of
scenes have been deleted in fact there
are deleted scenes in which pterodactyls
were supposed to attack the helicopter
when the characters are getting off it
was like all storyboarded they just
decided to go with this San Diego thing
and it all felt very tacked on it's
great filmmaking I mean there's amazing
special effects great practical stuff
it's very funny it's intense it's
exciting it's all really well done
it's not that I have a problem with the
way the sequence is handled it's just
the getting to it felt like such an
abrupt shift from everything else so I'm
not really faulting the filmmaking I'm
just faulting the storytelling and
getting to that scene because it just
felt like this extra edition almost like
a blu-ray alternate ending that went on
for a really long time but it's still a
lot of fun to see a t-rex storming
through San Diego and I watched this
movie today this movie is almost twenty
years old almost he's like 18 years old
and the effects are still magnificent
the final shot where you see the
pterodactyl flying and landing on the
branch and you had the T Rexes and all
the animals in the same area together it
looks beautiful it looks better than
some of the shots in the Jurassic world
trailer I mean it a lot of the shots in
the dress circle trailer bottom line is
I've always really loved the lost world
it has some problems it's not quite as
good as the first film but I respect
that it's a different movie I love Jeff
Cole
he's such an entertaining character his
arguments with Julianne Moore are so
well written I like Vince Vaughn in the
movie quite a bit too he's really good
in this film the San Diego sequence
feels rushed and the gymnastics scene is
dumb but in all honesty I don't have any
other flaws with the lost world I think
it's a fantastically fun movie if you go
into the movie knowing it's not going to
be quite as good and a little bit
different in the first film similar to
Temple of Doom I can't see you not
having fun with this film I'm going to
give the lost world Jurassic Park and a
- I think it's really good filmmaking
and I just watched the movie today I
actually think this movie has gotten
better with age I do think it is a film
that exists in a time period where we
were judging it way too harshly because
of that first film I really think this
movie has gotten better over time if
you're not a big fan of the movie try
rewatching it and just look at the
filmmaking in it because it's handled so
well that being said do yourself a favor
and never play the lost world game for
PlayStation 1 I bought this and I played
it today with my buddy after we watched
this movie uh yeah it's it's pretty much
impossible I hate it so guys I will be
back very soon with my review of
Jurassic Park 3 before Jurassic world
next month thank you so much as always
for watching guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
Benoist
Oh